>> I think it's a fantastic opportunity
for Curtin to show the state, the country and
the world that as an early adopter, this is
what a University should be about.
>> I think the moral and the safety issues of
driverless vehicles is actually important here.
>> Control is probably the
biggest stumbling block that we're going
to face in terms of human psychology and
increasing the adoption of autonomous vehicles.
>> It's just a question of how
many decisions will we let the vehicle
make for us and I think we will
eventually get to a point of the vehicle
making all the decisions for us.
>> Having an autonomous vehicle on a
University provides a safe environment
in which we can test this brand-new technology.
>> We're very interested in the
extent to which autonomous vehicles are
going to change society as a whole but
specifically in terms of the health
outcomes and they are vast and probably
completely underestimated at this point in time.
>> I'm really interested in
people's responses to the bus and to
the technology, answering questions like
will they perceive it as a danger to
public safety or do they think that it's
perfectly safe? How do they respond to
the idea of a vehicle with clearly no
driver here in this vehicle?
>> I like the idea of The Internet of Things
driving this because the bus can be a
thing on the internet where users can
interact in the way that potentially
creates new business environment.
>> I see the benefits on both sides, we get to work
with the University and understand how
we can solve some challenging problems
that we can see within our important
customers, but at the same time the
University can actually leverage a lot of
the solutions that we're working with
in a sort of a rapid prototype approach.
>> Having this kind of technology available
on Curtin campus enables us to watch
humans interacting with the technology,
so how do they feel about the technology
prior to exposure, how do they feel about
it afterwards, what are the sticking points,
what are the things that we need to
educate them about or tell them about to
enable them to be more accepting, longer
term of the technology.
>> The cars, the autonomous cars of the future will be
covered in sensors and they will have
all that information being fed into
effectively a machine learning device
that will make very good decisions.
>> So if you think about the fact that
we've got about 1,200 people a year
dying on Australian roads and another 35
thousand or so who end up in hospital,
that's close to 16 billion dollars
worth of expenditure just dealing with
that road trauma. The forecasts are that
when we have autonomous vehicles, they're
going to all but eradicate those costs
because most accidents are the result of
human error and that human error will
be taken out of the equation.
>> There's a lot more to it than just passenger
vehicles on the road. I think if you
apply the same ideas, autonomous vehicle
technology to trucks, to buses, to trains...
>> and with that will go all the supply
chain optimisation as well, so we'll
become much more efficient as how we
move things around the state.
>> It's all about the new era of mobility and
transportation, you don't have to buy car insurance
anymore, you don't have to worry about
parking in the big city.
>> The other kinds
of health benefits that we're looking at
are just the fact that people who
become socially isolated due to illness
or age because they can no longer hold
a license, they'll actually be able to stay mobile.
>> Well for a start I
think my kids are probably the last
generation that will need to get a driver's
license, which has always been a bit of a
teenage right of passage but that's gone.
The school run in the morning will
disappear, you'll just whistle for the
car, it'll pick the kids up and take them
off to school, having to leave work early
for soccer practice, all of that sort of
stuff will disappear. So parents who
feel like a taxi service will probably
appreciate the technology.
>> Having that bus here gives us a great opportunity to
develop new solutions and then hopefully
we can take those solutions and export
them globally.